PROFESSOR: In this
segment, we will
discuss the multinomial
model and the multinomial
probabilities, which are
a nice generalization
of the binomial probabilities.
The setting is as follows.
We are dealing with
balls and the balls come
into different colors.
There are r possible
different colors.
We pick a ball at random,
and when we do that,
there is a certain probability
Pi that the ball that we picked
has ith color.
Now, we repeat this process
n times independently.
Each time we get a ball
that has a random color.
And we're interested in the
following kind of question.
Somebody fixes for
us certain numbers--
n1, n2, up to nr that
add up to n, and asks us,
what is the probability
that when you carry out
the experiment, you get exactly
n1 balls of the first color,
exactly n2 balls of the
second color, and so on?
So the numbers n1, n2, up to
nr are fixed given numbers.
For a particular choice
of those numbers,
we want to calculate
this probability.
Now of course, this is
a more general model.
It doesn't necessarily deal
with balls of different colors.
For example, we might have
an experiment that gives us
random numbers, where the
numbers range from 1 up to r,
and at each time we get a
random number with probability
Pi we get a number
which is equal to i.
So we could use this to
model die rolls, for example.
And there's actually
a special case
of this problem, which
should be familiar.
Suppose that we have
only two colors,
and instead of
thinking of colors,
let us think of the
two possibilities
as being heads or tails.
And we can make the
following analogy.
Somebody gives us numbers
n1 and n2 that add up to n.
And we're interested
in the probability
that we get n1 of
the first color
and n2 of the second color.
Well, we could think of this
as a setting in which we
are asking for the
probability that we obtain
k heads and n minus k tails.
So the question of what is
the probability that we obtain
k heads and n minus k
tails is of the same kind
as what is the probability that
we get n1 of the first color
and n2 of the second color.
Now, if heads have a
probability p of occurring,
and tails has a probability
of 1 minus p of occurring,
then we would have
the following analogy.
The probability of
obtaining the first color,
which correspond to heads,
that would be equal to p.
The probability of obtaining
the second color, which
correspond to tails,
this would be 1 minus p.
Now, the probability
of obtaining k
heads in those n
independent trials--
we know what it is.
By the binomial
probabilities, it
is n choose k times
p to the k times one
minus p to the power n minus k.
Now we can translate this
answer to the multinomial case
where we're dealing with colors,
and we do these substitutions.
So n choose k is n factorial
divided by k factorial.
In this case, k is the same
as n1, so we get n1 factorial.
And then we are going to have
here n minus k factorial.
But n minus k corresponds to n2.
So here we get an n2 factorial.
And then p corresponds to p1
and p2 corresponds to 1 minus p.
So we get here p1 times p2.
n to the power n minus k,
again, by analogy, is n2.
So this is the form of the
multinomial probabilities
for the special case where
we're dealing with two colors.
Let us now look at
the general case.
Let us start with an
example, to be concrete.
Suppose that the number
of colors is equal to 3,
and that we're going to
pick n equal to 7 balls.
We carry out the
experiments, and we
might obtain an
outcome which would
be a sequence of this type.
So the first ball
had the color 1,
the second ball had
the first color,
the third ball had
the third color,
the fourth ball had the
first color, and so on.
And suppose that
this was the outcome.
One way of summarizing what
happened in this outcome
would be to say that we
had four 1s, we had two 2s,
and we had one 3.
We could say that this is
the type of the outcome.
It's of type 4, 2, 1--
that is, we obtained
four of the first color,
two of the second color,
and one of the third color.
This is one possible outcome.
What is the probability
of obtaining
this particular outcome?
The probability of obtaining
this particular outcome
is, using independence, the
probability that we obtain
color 1 in the first trial,
color 1 in the second trial,
color 3 in the third trial,
color 1 in the fourth trial,
color 2 in the next trial,
color 1 in the last trial.
And we put all the
factors together,
and we notice that this
is p1 to the fourth p2
to the second times p3.
It's not a coincidence that the
exponents that we have up here
are exactly the
count that we had
when we specified the type
of this particular outcome.
Generalizing from
this example, we
realize that the
probability of obtaining
a particular sequence of a
certain type, that probability
is of this form.
For each color, we
have the probability
of that color raised to
the power of how many times
that particular color
appears in a sequence.
So any particular sequence of
this type has this probability.
What we're interested
in is to find
the total probability
of obtaining
some sequence of this type.
How can we find
this probability?
Well, we will take
the probability
of each sequence of this type--
which is this much,
and it's the same
for any particular sequence--
and multiply with the number
of sequences of this type.
So how many sequences are
there of a certain type?
Let us look back at our example.
We had seven trials.
So let us number here
the different trials.
And when I tell you that
a particular sequence was
obtained, that's the
same as telling you
that in this set of trials,
we had the first color.
In this set of trials,
the fifth and sixth trial,
we had the second color.
And in this trial, the third
trial, we had the third color.
This is an alternative
way of telling you
what sequence we obtained.
I tell you at
which trials we had
the first color, at which trials
we had the second, at which
trials we had the third.
But What do we have here?
Here we have a partition of the
set of numbers from 1 up to 7
into three subsets.
And the cardinalities
of those subsets
are the numbers that appear here
in the type of the sequence.
The conclusion is that a
sequence of certain type
is equivalent, or can be
alternatively specified,
by giving you a partition
over this set of tosses, which
is the set from 1 up to n,
how many trials we've had,
a partition into subsets
of certain sizes.
So this allows us now
to count the number
of sequences of a certain type.
It's exactly the same as
the number of partitions,
and we know what this is.
And putting everything
together, the probability
of obtaining a sequence
of a certain type
is equal to the count
of how many sequences
do we have of the
certain type, which
is the same as the number of
partitions of a certain type,
times the probability of
any particular sequence
of that type that
we're interested in.
So this is a formula
that generalizes the one
that we saw before for the case
where we have only two colors,
and which corresponded to
the coin tossing setting.
And it is a useful
model, because you
can think of many situations in
which you have repeated trials,
and at each trial,
you obtain one out
of a finite set of
possible results.
There are different
You repeat those
trials independently.
And you may be interested in
the question of how many results
of the first kind, of the second
kind, and so on there will be.